when I was hungover in a test in college
I once spelled quarterback with a C so
so that gives you some I think when it
comes to spelling for me I like peaked
in fifth grade overall that say I'm a
pretty decent feller
am I gonna have to spell in my head oh
god this is the worst thing in the world
I hope I do better than I think that
I'll do misspelled misspelled am i s
feel like people await all right
M I SPE ll e d no - are there two S's PE
l led dama it's two S's in Savannah M is
spel led L led guarantee I think I got
that one guarantee G you ar e and te e
what that's [ __ ] GU a how do you
little kids do this without writing it
out G you a are a in T e he guarantee
okay
te that was right right a m te e
[Music]
Millenial that I can't spell millennial
I really don't out as fellows M I ye and
now M I ll e and I al I was it didn't I
see it's all the double that's just the
only thing is that like partial credit e
and I al e IA l e and i al
no really
Zachary oh Jesus
I read a lot of bar menu so hopefully I
can get this one based on muscle memory
D a Q Decker read the a qu i are i i are
i Zachary ah qu e RI e me i RI plus so
it's da i qu IR y who can't come up with
that this is brutal this I was not
expecting to do this bad yeah I
surprised myself I'm thrilled right now
who needs spellcheck I'm gonna remember
this forever I'm gonna know all I'm
gonna remember all of these words you
you like test me in ten years and I will
remember every single one of these